it was supposed to be fun tens of
thousands of Scouts coming together from
158 countries
that was until a heat wave hit the buwan
region of South Korea now hundreds of
teenagers are experiencing heat related
sicknesses and the government has been
forced to step in
from now on the government of the
Republic of Korea the central government
will take the lead and be in charge of
Safety Management and smooth operation
of the event until all the participants
leave
the world Scout Jamboree is described as
the world's largest Youth Camp bringing
together Scouts from all over the world
every four years countries take turns
hosting the event
but the Jamboree in South Korea has
faced criticisms with reports of
substandard bathrooms and sanitation on
the campsite
military doctors have been deployed to
the event with temperatures hitting 35
degrees Celsius that's proved too much
for some with thousands of American and
British Scouts pulling out of the
Jamboree all together the problems with
this go Way Beyond the heat there's none
of food there's not enough water oh 100
nightmare I mean I think he's making the
best and he's been positive about the
the people he's met but the living
conditions and the the disorganization
has just crushed him and he's crushed
about having to spend the next week on
Army base
the world organization of the Scout
movement has called on South Korea to
shorten the event bus organizers have
committed to salvaging the Jamboree and
the government has spent millions of
dollars to improve conditions the
organizing committee will continue to
work with government Ministries the
world Scout committee and the Korean
Scout committee to protect the
participants from the heat wave as much
as possible and make it a safe event
local media are reporting the situation
as a National Disgrace
but for many of these teenagers it was
supposed to be the trip of a lifetime
Alex beard Al Jazeera